Just before we get started,
some of you might know that I have another channel called mega projects,
which is all about mega projects. I've mentioned it here before.
If you don't subscribe to that channel, well, please do bus by popular demands.
I wanted to cover things that weren't quite mega enough for that channel.
So I started a new channel. It's called a side project.
You can see what we did that a couple of secrets, Soviet space weapons,
world war two's greatest airplane.
Some of history's lost treasures and the movements of London bridge from London
to a random town in America,
stuff like that knew that he goes three times a week on that channel.
So if you're thinking, Oh, Simon doesn't make enough videos for me. Well,
don't worry. Hasn't I was assigned projects and subscribe.
There is a link below and let's get started,
Who was Arkin Arsen for 3,300 years.
This question would have yielded only puzzled expressions as his deeds were
considered.
So vile and outrageous that the man who was once Pharaoh of Egypt was
condemned to damnation Memorial.
I a process where others tried to eliminate all mentions of him from history and
make it look like he never existed for thousands of years.
This was the case.
It wasn't until the late 19th and early 20th centuries when modern archeologists
excavated the lost city of a minor.
And we were able to rediscover the reign of Akhenaten.
So what did he do? That was so heinous? Well,
he was arguably ancient Egypt's greatest heretic. I can,
Artan abandoned the traditional gods who have been worshiped for thousands of
years. And instead instituted a new religion called art aneurysm,
which was centered around the worship of art in the sun disk.
He also moved to the capital of Egypt from Thebes to a new city that he built
called. Amaanah also called arc and art. And during his reign for this reason,
the timespan that covers his reign,
as well as those that immediately followed is also referred to as the amount of
period, the extent to which all can autumn suppress the old forms of religious
expression. It's still a matter of debate among scholars,
but the people of ancient Egypt would definitely not happy with him almost
immediately. After he died,
they got to work restoring the old ways and the pharaohs who followed distanced
themselves from his beliefs. Nowadays,
we're much more familiar with his son teaching common,
who realistically didn't actually do anything of note in his lifetime.
But today we seek to rectify this a bit by taking a look at Argonaut and the
heretical Pharaoh who launched a religious revolution.
[Inaudible].
I can, Austin was born sometime in the first half of the 14th century, BC,
most likely during the 1370s, he was part of Egypt's 18th dynasty.
That first one of the new kingdom,
which arguably saw the Egyptian EMBA reached the peak of its power.
Most of the pharaohs we've covered so far like tutoring,
common had Shep sprouts.
And so mostly the third have all been part of the same dynasties.
It's pretty fair to say that this was a crucial POS in the history of Egypt.
I can Austin's father was Farrah Amenhotep the third also known as Amenhotep the
magnificent. He is generally considered one of ancient Deidre. It was gracious.
Rulers presiding over our lengths that he reign of almost 40 years marked by
prosperity, peace and stability. I can Arden's mother was Ty,
the Pharaoh's great Royal wife.
He was actually the second Psalm that the two had together and was not
originally planned to take over the throne. However, his older brother,
a crown Prince that most a died of an unknown cause sometime during the second
half of their father's reign and therefore, how can art?
And they came the next in line. He was an called Akhenaten at the time,
of course,
this name was roughly translated to one who is serviceable to Arten
and he only adopted it as Pharaoh. Once he institutes it,
isn't you religious policies up until the last point he was Amenhotep the
fourth, but we'll stick to Akhenaten's.
You avoid a lot of confusion with his father.
We cannot tell you almost anything about his early life.
Some Egyptologists speculate that he may have served as a high priest before
taking the throne because his brother had done the same while he was still the
success errands.
Maybe this is where he first developed his strong devotion to the art,
and also spelled Asian this day,
he actually predated our economic and by a long way,
it's first mentioned date back to the old kingdom.
Although back then it seemed to be simply a word used to refer to the sun disk
itself. And it wasn't an actual deity,
but it's rather an element of the sun, God, by the middle kingdom, though,
there were already references to Otten as a creator.
So at some point centuries before and came along art and had already
morphed into a sort of solidarity and other hotly debated aspect of
Akhenaten's life is when exactly he took over the throne.
There are some scholars who assert that Amenhotep the third mate,
his son co regions, while he was still Pharaoh,
many others argue strongly against this view.
And even the lengths of the code Regency is heavily disputed for all purposes.
We're going to assume that [inaudible] became the new Pharaoh of Egypt after the
death of his father. This happens around 1353 BC Pharaoh.
Amenhotep the third died in his late forties or early fifties and is 38 or
39th retinal year. And he was buried in the Valley of the Kings.
His son followed him to the throne still under the name almond hotel.
The fourth. It was around this time that he married his great Royal wife.
Never TT.
He, yes, back in orphans, rain where a traditional, for lack of a better word,
where he followed the regular customs of the time and mainly continued policies
and practices that had been set out by his father.
He expressed his worship of the Otten, but not in an over away.
This wasn't considered unusual because Amenhotep the third also emphasize the
worship of the art. And as a callback to their ancestors,
between the middle kingdom and new kingdom,
there was a span of time dubbed the intermediate period.
It was considered a dark time for Egypt,
as parts of the lambs were not ruled by native adoptions,
but rather by Hexall salsa group of people from the Lavonne's who arrived in the
area and took over in the 17th century, BC,
eventually the heck SaaS were defeated and driven away permanently by Moz.
The first who founded the 18th dynasty, the one that we're in right now,
the point is that after the pixels were gone,
the pharaohs who followed were eager to get back to their roots,
they wanted to do a way with the traditions and culture of the heck sauce and
bring back many customs and religious practices from their forefathers,
from the middle kingdom and beyond Zinn's. Well,
that is how the arson entered the Egyptian public consciousness once more.
Amenhotep the third might've worshiped often,
but he never neglected a moon who by that point had become one of the most
important gods in the Egyptian Pantheon and the patron devotee of Thebes.
In fact,
I'm insignificance during the 18th dynasty grew so much that he began being
identified alongside RA the SunGard as a single entity named
almond. Rob,
the first indication that Akhenaten had plans of his own came a few years into
his reign. When he scheduled a scent festival for himself,
this was one of Egypt's oldest traditions.
It was a sort of Jubilee where the grands feast meant to celebrate the original
unification between upper and lower Egypt. Traditionally,
a Farrah organized his first sent festival once he rained for 30 years and in
three year increments from then on,
I can often did it after only two or three years.
The reason for this has been widely speculated.
Some scholars think he was mentally preparing himself for the more drastic steps
he was about to take others believe I can.
Austin wanted to symbolically link his reign to that of his father.
So he organized a SED festival just three years after the previous.
One of Amenhotep the third and some concluded that the Pharaoh simply saw it as
a convenient excuse for him to build loads of new monuments and dentals
dedicated to do the Otten without anyone raising an eyebrow.
Indeed the greatest one of all was the temple complex constructed right outside
Karnak named GAM Pitocin or Otten his founds,
which went against Egyptian building conventions by having no roof so that the
sunlight could freely enter the complex. By the fifth year of his reign,
the Pharaoh decided it was time for a true revolution. He changed Israel.
Tottori officially adopting the name Akhenaten and instituting the worship of
the arson throughout his kingdom.
He expressed his devotion to the sun disk in several HINNs and poems.
The most famous of which is the gratin to the art and the composition of 13
stanzas, which was found in described on several rock tombs.
Unsurprisingly many Egyptians were outraged by economics and particularly the
priests who were about to lose the majority of that power influence and wealth.
However,
the Pharaoh was not an idiot and he knew that he would not be able to pull off
his religious reform without support from anyone.
And he got that support from the army.
The kingdom was coming off from a period of prosperity.
So the soldiers were already pretty content,
but I can art and still made sure to praise and celebrate them whenever the
opportunity arose as well as maintain good relations with his military leaders.
Clearly this worked as there were no major uprisings during his reign and the
disavowal of the cult of art and only took place after his death because of his
actions. Zack and Austin has been heralded by some modern scholars.
The first Banu theist in history,
meaning the first person to express belief in a single God,
others reject this label and qualify as rain more as a henotheistic period of
Egypt's, meaning that while worship was focused on a single diety,
he didn't necessarily reject to the possible existence of others either way.
OCHIN often wanted nothing to do with the old gods of Egypt anymore.
And he felt that his worship of the art and needed to be concentrated in a
Virgin site.
One that was free from the touch and influence of the form of Pantheon.
[Inaudible].
As shocking as Akhenaten's abandonment of the old gods was.
So it was his decision to leave.
Seebs the city that had functioned as Egypt's Capitol for the grades of bards of
its history up until then.
But the Pharaoh wanted to found a new capital in pristine lands.
HR is an uninhabited size on the Eastern bank of the Nile and took around 20,000
people with him to his new sediments.
He called this Akon tartan or horizon of the atom,
but it is better known by its later name.
Amaanah obviously building a new city from scratch in a short period of time was
a huge undertaking.
And there is grim evidence to suggest that the people then Amano worked to the
bone once the largest cemetery in Amaanah was excavated,
modern archeologists found the remains of 432 people.
The ones whose age was established 70% died before the age of 35,
while only nine people live past 50.
And also knew that the children had the growth stunted you to malnutrition.
While many adults had spinal damage from being overworked and even darker
picture is painted by another cemetery.
This time located near the Royal limestone quarry,
a whopping 92% of the individuals buried.
There were under 25 years old while half of them were under 15 Amaanah might've
been the ideal city in the mind of Arkin Artan,
but all indications seem to suggest that he only cared about himself and his God
while the people of Amaanah lived in miserable conditions and were being worked
to death in order to cope with the construction demands of the Farrow build
created a new type of stone block called Talla tops made out of limestone.
They were much smaller than the blocks used in Egyptian construction,
but they were also cut to a standard size, which was not typically done before.
Theoretically, this made them more efficient, but they still did not catch on.
And the usage of talent times ended shortly after the amount of periods.
It probably would not surprise you to learn that the main structures in a mana
where the raw palaces were Akhenaten's and temples for the autumn,
the main place of worship was great temple of the Austin and the center of the
city while the secondary small art and temple was located near to the RA
palaces, like all other art and symbols,
they had two features that distinguished them from traditional Egyptian places
of worship.
They were open now with no roof and they also did not feature any cult images of
the arson, which was in fact,
a recurring SIEM and organism while the other gods were commonly depicted as
having human bodies and human or animal heads,
Zack and Alton insisted that they often was everywhere in every one and thus
transcended the need for any kind of physical form. Therefore the autumn,
it was always depicted as only a disk emitting certain res something else that
came out of a mana was a new art style dubbed simply the Amman or off style.
Again, it did not last longer than Akhenaten's reign,
but some works have survived and they create a pretty stark contrast to the
traditional ancient Egyptian art. The most striking differences concerned,
the ways humans were depicted and the amount of stall they were told her and
more slender.
The facial features where Ilan gauged in the chest hands and legs with sin while
the stomach and thighs were often bloated,
the same skin color was used for men and women in art and art and himself was
depicted with feminine features.
Some Egyptologists believed that this was actually a more realistic view of what
the Pharaoh really looks like because he might have suffered from one or more
genetic disorders like Marfan's syndrome,
which caused elongated extremities or Kleinfelter syndrome,
which led to male breast enlargements.
It is speculated that other pharaohs from the 18th dynasty also suffered from
these elements, but this is yet to be proven conclusively.
How can all of a sudden ruled Egypt for approximately 17 years?
And his reign was clearly dominated by his devotion to the arson,
which became increasingly fanatical as the years,
went by not satisfied with simply building a new capital dedicated to his God.
He later has older timbales dismantled and their priests killed as he ordered
the names of the old gods. Be chiseled out of all,
cravings from John stelae to small tablets.
We don't actually have a lot of detailed information about what happens in Egypt
during the reign of Akhenaten's because of the whole damnation memorializing and
having all mentions of him destroyed.
But we do know a lot more about his international relations,
thanks to a treasure trove of information that somehow survived known as the
Amaanah letters.
This consists of over 380 tablets written in the Akkadian language,
using cuneiform that mostly represent diplomatic correspondence from neighboring
city, administrators and Kings to the Pharaoh.
The tone you used in the tablets changes, depending on who the sender was,
some of them came from vassals of Egypt.
So naturally the tone was very deferential addressing [inaudible] is the son
my Lord, while referring to themselves as his sevens, others,
while still cordials came from rulers of similar rank,
like the Kings of maintaining your battle on,
and the tone reflected their equal status,
regardless of the way they were written. Many letters had similar content.
They expressed displeasure, disappointment, concern, and uneasiness economics.
And for neglecting some of his international duties,
some of these were specific, for example,
the King of Matana to Schrott up complains in one tab,
it's the dock and Autin seemingly reneged on a deal made by his father to give
the King solid gold statues, his dowry for a princess bride from atonic.
It would seem that I can often sent to [inaudible] gold plated statues. Instead,
many of us has concerns the most pressing issue in the region at that time,
the rise of a dangerous foe, the Hittites,
and they showed how little lacking art and cared about matters that had nothing
to do with the awesome, it was. In fact,
during economic sins reign that the Hitomi has reached the peak of that power.
And by the time dude in common games of the throne,
the Hittite empire was just as strong as Egypt. First,
the Madani asked economic and for assistance and that war with the Hittites,
but that was no help. Forthcoming. In fact,
Egypt hope to Curry favor with the new regional power is withdrew all support to
Madani allowing the King that you assassinate Tish Rotter and sank his
capital of wash. Connie. Of course,
this only serve to show the rest of the world that Egypt was we can vulnerable.
So the Hittites pressed the attack and went into Syria wet that West city States
and kingdoms that were vassals of Egypt since theoretically under its
protection.
The city States that weren't conquered were angered by Egypt's inaction and they
rebelled prompting Argonaut. And to lose the territory,
he used strapped a minion over in Syria, as far as we can tell, he never.
I attempted to get it back.
The last years of Akhenaten's reign, not one big question, Mark,
the most confusing and controversial aspects was his successions.
The couple of years in between the reigns of Akhenaten and his son to Tom
common,
the full name is that we know there were two other fairies with very short
reigns between father and son smack and RN Neff and a ferritin. However,
that is pretty much what we know who they were,
how they were connected to economics and why they became Pharos, uh,
all still mysteries that spur debates among Egyptologists.
We're not sure if [inaudible] was male or female,
but some evidence may suggest that he served as code region during the last
years of Akhenaten's life.
Some believed that the same can be said for [inaudible] who was a woman and may
have been one of the Pharaoh's daughters or more likely the new name of
Nefertiti. Once she became fair, right in our own right economics and died,
sucker 1330, six BC of unknown causes afterwards,
men could Carre ans NEFA never attend either a rule together as co regions or
one or the other, or both of them had individual reigns as Pharaoh.
We simply cannot say with any certainty and it wasn't until it's in 10
increments,
took the throne circus 1334 BC that the historical record became clearer.
This is because King tox was still a young boy when he became Pharaoh and his
advisors made most of the decisions for him.
They realized that the cult of the art and had no chance of surviving without
hacking art. And so they steadily made changes,
do revert back to the old ways and the old gods and Shaun everything
done by the form of fair.
This included the monitor itself as the city was abandoned.
When the Capitol was reverted back to Thebes, it was still standing though.
It wasn't actually destroyed until later when a Pharaoh called Horam Hab came to
power, he was more thorough when it came to wiping out the amount of period from
history.
So we had the temples and monuments built by economics and dismantled and then
recycled for new structures.
That's why they were taught about ants from Amaanah that we used as filler
material for the pillars at Luxor, as far as [inaudible] was concerned,
his wish you won't be surprised to find out was to be buried in a Monat.
You had a Royal tomb built for himself in the local necropolis called the
[inaudible] extra chambers NEFA TT. And one of his daughters who died young,
maybe even during childbirth, he said,
let's a tune be made for me in the Eastern mountains of astronauts and less,
my burial will be made in it in the millions of Jubilees,
which the arson I father to create for me,
let the burial of the King's chief wife NEFA TTB made in the millions of years,
which my father to create for heart.
And that's also the barrier of the Kings daughter be made in it.
You probably won't be surprised to learn that his wish was ignored.
I can Artan was buried in his tomb initially,
but it was later moved to the Valley of the Kings and his Royal tomb was
desecrated where exactly he ended up is again, a matter of some disputes.
Most of Janice, his final resting place was KV 55,
a small undecorated single chamber to which only contained a single adult mummy
placed in a sarcophagus whose facial features had been destroyed as well.
All names and personal identifiers.
The identity of the mummy is a controversial topic made even more confusing by
the fact that it was originally designed to be a woman.
The body was intact male. Although the coffin itself was designed for a woman.
Many believe this is economics.
And although others have positive that the mummy may belong to the obscure smack
and Carre modern DNA test indicated that the mummy was related to teaching
common,
but other scholars criticized them saying that the DNA was too degraded and the
mummies handled by so many people over time that the results would be an
accurate, this is another contentious point for the time being,
but is somehow fitting,
given all the other aspects of Akhenaten's reign as a seemingly
destined to go down in history is arguably the most controversial Farrow in the
history of Egypt. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe. Also, please do check about other channel.
I mentioned side projects, which is linked to below. Thank you for watching.
[Inaudible].